hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
second may be the story of the Mishima
families in a battle with demons in an
ever-expanding power struggle but there
were over 70 playable characters
spanning the series so there's lots of
little stories to uncover each character
receives their own ending to each game
which leads to so messed up things to
witness some funny some dark as hell and
so much downright weird here's my pick
of the 7 strangest Tekken endings you
will see
[Music]
let's start with Tekken 6 and the
relationship between Paul Phoenix and
the mall family in the past they've been
chased by bears they've hit the gym
together and then hit one another a few
times in the face and groin well in
Tekken 6 after successfully winning the
tournament and becoming rich beyond
their wildest dreams
Marshall makes Pau and Steve a pizza to
celebrate which goes down a little bit
too well ready my special recipe pizza
it's about time it looks delicious
this is good did you know diarrhea is
hereditary yeah it runs in Eugene too
with that off run Marshall with all his
hard-earned cash
Heihachi final cinematic in Tekken 6 is
a little dark he binds his son and
grandson and tosses them into space it
doesn't go completely to plan of course
[Music]
what happened next did they die on
re-entry to the earth or is the devil
gene going to keep them safe at this
point I wanted to include a space-themed
upon but I need a little longer to
Planet planet get it close it doesn't
matter crack on on the ps2 Tekken 5
brothers this sexy ending featuring Lee
ever wanted to check out hey a cheese
butch eeks here fill your boot
[Music]
Lee has Tekken her hat she hostage after
winning the Iron Fist tournament and
keeps him as his personal slave to who I
can't get he actually bought out of my
head
but it's a great book though isn't it
anyway let's move on from that bum nope
before it becomes a pain in the ass
voyeurism camera you the sumo wrestling
pervert has taken part in many Iron Fist
tournament but his actions in Tekken Tag
Tournament 2 were a little far out to
say the least
alum just let you see this for yourself
[Music]
a Gundam watch this one give us
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't think I can make a pun from this
one and he even has voyeuristic
tendencies with his lunchtime salad he
has a thing for Caesar dressing he's
addressing please sorry that's just
terrible for a terrible apology subject
Awards Universal to really display house
Ridge the Tekken world is here's a
kangaroo beating off a velociraptor why
pick up Tekken that's why weird happen
fear it's even stranger to think that
the rapper named Alex almost usurped
daddy kangaroo Roger - if that doesn't
hit you in the field then you don't
understand great character development
and stellar voice acting
[Music]
maybe another animal-based ending which
will startle you is from Tekken Tag 2
and kuma's ending where he's taking
pictures with Japanese school girls at
this point it sounds alright doesn't it
once he sees the look on his life across
the pack yeah it's a panda we live in a
multicultural world don't we don't judge
well his sexual urges get the best of
him birth he slobbers all over one of
the school girls which is this cross but
luckily he doesn't get the chance to do
whatever he's planning to that Panda
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Tekin is a lot darker than I remember
[Music]
back in second five and the squabble
between assassins Anna and Nina
throughout the years they've been taking
nude pics of each other and playing
pranks on one another to get the
limelight well in second five they both
star in a film together the set up
remains the same a fight scene being
shot
[Music]
but depending on his character you
either see Anna slice off all of Nina's
armor to embarrass her of course not
that I'm not a fan of digital lady bits
but Nina's ending is a bit more shocking
after losing the scrapper she oxen
leaves and
blows her sister to pieces along with
all the bystanders I get sibling rivalry
but murdering your sister is not the
right thing to do although I have
thought about it a few times and now I'm
incriminating myself so let's finish
here so that was seven of the strangest
ending themes in the second theory do
you agree with my list if I missed
anything please let me know or by the
way who is the greatest character in
second history for me it neither we rang
or maybe Jin Kazama what do you say I'm
I don't from PlayStation grenade after
you next time
[Music]